you're going to be absolutely horrified
after you hear how evil this country is
a journalist in this country started
criticizing the Royal Prince which is a
really bad idea so he fled to America in
fear for his own life but instead of
keeping it low profile this journalist
joined the Washington Post so he could
keep trashing the world Prince so the
Royal Prince thought I've gotta teach
this guy a lesson so the Royal Prince
waited he waited for the journalist to
enter his Consulate in turkey and once
he was inside the prince had his men
literally chopped the journalists into
pieces the message was clear mess with
me and this would be your fate but the
prince's Revenge was far from over yet
his next Target was the Washington Post
the paper that allowed this journalist
to trash him in the first place and who
owns the Washington Post Jeff Bezos
that's right the prince of Saudi Arabia
just butchered a journalist and now he
was coming after the guy behind Amazon
subscribe for part two